All right, let's go and get started everybody.
Thank you for coming on time. I was not even looking at
my watch. I didn't know that we'd run a little bit over but let's good
to hear everybody visiting and enjoying one another
we're gonna get started with a quick review
and some of you are saying well, I've been
here every week. Why do we have to review last week?
We had 27 brand new people and
so each week. We will have brand
new folk. And so we're gonna
get them caught up but probably the most
important reason is that we absolutely have to
know the disciple making pathway in
the disciple making Essentials and disciple
making definitions and then they're just some basic foundational
facts. The one that I'm
going to share tonight, maybe if not, the one of
the most important facts and so that's that's why I review
so let's go ahead and start with a pathway.
You've seen this before if you've been with us, but we have
worships on Sundays where we meet
here and but we're not satisfied with
someone just coming and sitting in worship and not participating. We
like to encourage them into one of our equipping groups.
The the equipping groups are men's groups
and women's groups and parents groups and
all different kinds of groups. But but one of the things
that surprised me is just how many people come to
our community groups last week. We had a raise of hands and it
was well over 90% of our people involved in community groups
and that is a great sign for a church. But but
what I'm challenging Community groups to do is
to to be thinking forwardly about
how do we move Beyond just
Um community group relational environment
into more of a deeper more
intimate more transparent environment and the
way we do that and this is our sweet spot is through our
community group. So here's our pathway. We're not
satisfied with just
Sitting and listening even though there's value in
that and it's not going away. We want to go beyond just
sitting and listening and Beyond.
guys
my mom calls every night and
By the way, she doesn't just call once this is gonna happen at
least three times. And so Shirley would
I mean Carol, would you like to call my mom and say hey Phil's
in front of lots of people and they're all
laughing for some reason. All right, if it happens again Carol's
gonna call. That's the way it's gonna work. All right, so sorry about
that. So that's that's our pathway. And now
we're gonna look at the essentials. I ask you
the very first night to do it and I'm gonna do it again tonight repeat after me
intentional leader.
relational environment
and reproducible process
that those are the essentials and and here's
my challenge to you tonight. We're not making
disciples so much as we are challenging those of
you who are feeling so led to
become that intentional leader. We
would love for at least half of the folks who've come
to learn what it means to make a disciples to think.
You know, I'm gonna give this a try. I'm gonna I'm gonna try
this out. I have been praying about and I'm
gonna I've got two or three people that I'm going to invite. Let's
talk about that invitation for just a minute.
when you're an intentional leader you
this is the wrong way to do it. I want to
disciple you and you could use it. Okay, that's
the wrong way. All right, the better way would be
to say I need you to pray about something. I'm starting
a group and we're going to we're going to look into
what it means to be a disciple and I need your
help. I need somebody like you in my
group because that's exactly what we're doing. We don't have and
this is not Jesus in The Twelve. All right.
This is fellow broken sojourners that
are working trying to get through this Maze of
life. And so I want I know you I've I
really care about you and I really think you
could help our group.
And so when you when you started off like
that a you're an intentional leader then immediately it's easier
to have a relational environment and one of
the first things I say when we meet together is that if we're
still meeting together in two or three years, we're
getting that that we're here to
reproduce ourselves. And one day my prayer is
that each of you will have a micro group. And so and
then this is what's going to happen over
the next 10 weeks. I've got
bad news next week. We're not meeting on the
calendar. We have a family equipping thing is that
is Wendy here.
windy
I don't believe you not for a second.
I'm looking back in my admin because she never lies to me my wife on the other
hand. I'm just kidding you.
No, no. Hey, if the calendar says it then you'll
be here and I'll be ready for you.
But I thought when he was going to be here to announce this the next week anyway.
Now you're beginning to see some of my strengths and weaknesses. So.
Okay, not next week with the week after okay. All
right, so
But but that's that is over the next 10
to 12 weeks. What we're going to be doing is
as when we started you each had
a leader and what your leader is
going to be doing intentionally is by
saying. Hey next week, would you lead the prayer time?
And going to ask somebody else in the micro group not micro
group to lead and they're not doing that because
they're tired or they don't have the decided not to pray
anymore or something. What they're doing is they're they're
giving them opportunities to lead. And then
what we're going to do is we're going to you I lead
you watch we discuss next week. I lead
I offer you a sliver of leadership. You lead
we discuss week after that is that you lead
and I watch and we discuss the week and eventually you
lead and I'm not even there, right? So
we're trying to reproduce ourselves and that's what's what
why it is. So essential last week we
looked at for the first time our official definition of what is
a disciple one who's following Jesus being changed
by Jesus and committed to the mission of Jesus disciple making
and so I want that just to roll
off your tongue because it's gonna be very very important that we're focused on
the same Target. All right, and then
this is the
The thing that we've done before is I wanted to
show you that down here in the large group the worship service.
There's not a lot of space for the
kinds of things that require transparency.
Let's just do this. I'm going to be I've been here long enough. I can be
a little bit honest with you. How many of you been here on a Sunday morning and didn't want
to be
Anybody all right. Hey give your hand
down and now you're gonna confessions of dishonesty. Yeah,
sometimes we just come to
church but our hearts are not in it
and you can actually get by with that in a
worship service but in a in a
community group, if you're just sitting there somebody might say is everything. Okay, and
you can say yeah, it's finally leave me alone and they will but not
over here not in the micro group. We are intentionally
keeping it small and gender-based so
that we can achieve and arrive at not
just conversations but conversations that
are transparent and conversations that are intimate and
conversations that will result in
accountability. I need you guys to pray for me because when
I came to church this morning, I didn't want to be here.
You can't say that to a person during the shaking of
the hands, you know.
All right, so moving on so this is something we
else we we learned last week and that is the ultimate result
of disciple making is transformation. What
is the disciple someone who's following Jesus someone who's
being changed by Jesus? We don't want
I mean Jesus takes us just as
we are but he loves us too much to leave us there. He wants
us to grow into His Image by his grace for
God's glory. That's what it means to enjoy him.
Bring him glory into enjoy him. We're transforming into
the image of his son. And so that is accomplished through
a development of lifelong practices one
word answers. What are some lifelong practices
that we're going to learn in this Township anybody?
Prayer, yeah. Yeah. I heard that one. No, I
didn't ask me that. What's it? What's another last long
practice?
Yeah, Bible Study Bible engagement. Not just
study but reading and hearing and preaching
and memorizing and meditating and obeying especially
right what else Bible engagement prayer?
What else?
Yeah devotional life I am.
I didn't there was a time in my life that I had
to be very intentional about getting up to going and
doing that. And now for some reason in my life. I can't
wait to get up in the mornings and start off with Jesus and
a cup of coffee in that order. Right
so devotional life, there's Community where
you're definitely involved in
the lives of people and challenging them.
To to grow in their faith.
There's also evangelism where we're living
scent looking for opportunities for God to put us in Divine appointments and
have gospel conversations. So these are some
of the lifelong practices practices now look
in your my wife
asked me to do this and so I'm gonna do this. All right,
we're going to look on page four of
week three last week's couldn't
find where we were what I hand out to
you is so much more than what we'll be able to study in the first 15 minutes.
Okay, and so but but Jesus
was a disciple maker and we
see over and over and all of the gospels
based upon his commandment in Matthew 28,
18 19 and 20 that he was doing that. He
was making disciples of his followers. And what
would I love about the story of the disciples is
that it's our story now listen
to me. Jesus could have picked anybody. He wanted
to be his disciples. He could have picked a list
of extraordinarily educated and
profoundly capable people, but
he didn't right. In fact,
it was just the opposite in Acts for 13
He says now when they saw the boldness of Peter and
John and perceived that they were what uneducated and
common NIV says ordinary
men they were astonished
Why because they recognized that they had been with
Jesus. So Jesus was a disciple maker and
it's not an accident that an intentional
leader like Jesus would pick people from all
different walks of life.
As a matter of fact, he intentionally chose
a wide variety of people from all walks
and stations of life and all became disciples
who may disciples in their own way. Think about
this. This is not an accident. We're not
trying to create a cookie cutter disciple that
you will make a disciple of the way. God
has created you to make a disciple out of someone who I could
never make a disciple of
If I went to one of my neighbors and I said hey, you
know a lady who I don't
know. She's let's just say
she's in her 30s. I've got some of those I said,
hey, I want you to pray about someone which group she's gonna
like get back from me. You're a creepy old man. Leave me
alone. But but some of you would have that that inroad
right? So think about
that God has created us who we are to reach people like
us so that we can continue to take this
gospel message to the ends of
the Earth and that was jesus' design from the
very beginning. They were professionals.
Luke was a doctor Matthew was a tax collector.
They were Housewives prostitutes. You remember
the story Mary Magdalen. She
was a probably a prostitute who
was once before a demon possessed person. So I think
Jesus is pretty good. Pretty much got the gamut covered Tradesmen
politician rich and poor all were
Disciples of Jesus. All right. Now, let's
talk about the one of the most profound facts of
this entire disciple making experience.
And that is this the holy spirit is
the teacher. What is the holy spirit? He's the
teacher who's the teacher the Holy Spirit now
listen to this.
Jesus in John 14 was talking about
when he left and the disciples
weren't excited about him leaving. They had given up everything to follow
him. Right? And this is what he tells him truly truly.
I say to you now, that's a Greek idiom that
says listen and listen closely. What I'm
about to say, you need to hear whoever believes
in me will also do the works that I do
and greater Works than these he will
do.
Because I'm going to the father whatever you ask in
my name this I will do.
That the father may be glorified in the son
if you ask anything in my name, I will do it.
If you love me, you'll keep my Commandments and
so we've heard that passage before but have you
ever connected it with how it's going to get done?
Which is the very next verse?
And I will ask the father.
And he will give you another helper. That's
Capital H.
To be with you forever. Even the spirit
of Truth. So the holy spirit is the teacher now,
I know this about a young about a
new disciple maker. I know you're thinking in your
mind. I don't think I'm ready for this. I don't
qualified. I've never done anything like this.
I don't think I can do this. No one's going
to want to listen to me. In fact, what would I
teach anyone?
Well, you've got the wrong concept.
You're not the teacher the holy spirit is
the teacher as a matter of fact, this is really
really important. It's very clear that Jesus.
Jesus is clear that the disciple making is
is it's it's completely dependent on
the role of the Holy Spirit. The holy spirit is
the only one that will do the transforming work within someone.
No human being can do
that. Right? So with that
and I just want to take that off your plate you don't
You don't have to worry about this. You just have to be obedient and humble
and and enter into a
relationship where you guys can be genuine and open and
authentic and as you're studying scripture together, you can
say and and frankly, this is one of the very best lessons
instead of saying well, this is what I believe the Bible
says today you're saying man.
This one really stomped on my toes.
And then also they they pick up what what
and then you tell them and they say yeah, I feel
the same thing. I underlined it my Bible and you start to be honest with
one another about what are we going to work on together as
people who are trying to become more like Christ,
so
Let's move on. So this is
from your book The invest in
a few by Craig Etheridge. And he
he said the first dimension of a disciple is
he's devoted to Jesus and and I would say yeah,
I believe that but then it's clarified in the very next sentence.
That is this person has become convinced that
Jesus is the Christ and salvation is found
and no one else but him this is where disciple making
begins. Let's talk about why that is okay.
The Bible is also clear that when we enter into
a relationship with Jesus and our sins are Justified past
present and future sins are Justified that
we then receive the Holy Spirit and
who's the teacher?
the Holy Spirit who does the transforming the Holy
Spirit and so the very first step in
becoming a disciple and a disciple maker is that
these they're devoted to Jesus knowing that that
they've found it salvation is found in
no one else one of the things you could discover when your discipling
is that this is a person
Here She is again. You got a
lover.
Oh, yeah, somebody wants me to answer it.
All right, just answer. Hi, Mom.
Excuse me. Just a minute. All right.
The tricky part when you're my age and you get stopped like that.
You got to go back remember what you were talking about?
Okay, so so when
you receive the Lord and He
justifies you of your sins you then begin the
process that's justification. The next stage is
sanctification. That means that you're being changed being
set apart being transformed and that has
to start with the Holy Spirit. And so one
of our leaders ask me.
He said I'm thinking in terms
of evangelism. Is it wrong to have someone
in your micro group that may not know the Lord?
And I said well no, it's not wrong
to do that. As a matter of fact, I don't think there
should be a serious a separation
in between discipleship and evangelism. I believe that discipleship is
evangelism and evangelism is discipleship. Right? But
but I also want you to understand that I
it's impossible for someone
to begin the the ministry of
reconciliation to unto South sanctification without
the work of the holy spirit in
their life. And so that's
That is exactly what I'm talking about there. All
right, what are we doing here?
There we go. Now this next graphic is
this is not a theological. Graphic. This
is a practical graphic. Okay, and before
we get to The Graphic, let me say one more thing as you're
meeting with your micro group, you're listening
for things like this.
Yeah, I was raised in the church.
Is that evidence of salvation?
No.
my parents
We're both ministers.
Is that evidence of Salvation? No, it's not
Jesus and anything else. It's Jesus
alone. Amen. And we have
the story of Nicodemus a very
very devout Pharisee who
came to Jesus genuinely seeking and
and what did Jesus said you need to
do? He said you must be born again. So it's not
about your religiosity. It's not about your knowledge of
scripture. It's not about anything other than
you having a relationship with Jesus, which I
wanted to finish by by looking at this graphic. Okay,
we will look for the next several
weeks at these stages of spiritual growth
and this is simply a graphic tool that helps you.
Assess where you belong in
this disciple-making effort and
you will find yourself somewhere in this
graphic initially before Christ. We're
all not just lost but
we're spiritually dead.
And this is just a simple
way at looking at these different different stages.
And just like Nicodemus he was a religious
man devoted to his
rituals and to his traditions and he didn't become a
Pharisee without learning significant parts of Torah.
But Jesus said unless you're born again. You
cannot see the kingdom of God. So when a
person
Prays to receive Christ and God does that miraculous
work of justification in their lives? They
receive the Holy Spirit and now they can begin that the
next step and that is growing to be more like
him. That's the process of sanctification. So let's look
at this.
So here we are spiritually then.
and
Ephesians 2 says you who were once dead?
All right, and so it's not just having a bad
day. It's not just
needs to work harder. It's none of
that stuff you you that and that's the miracle of Salvation
folks is that it's not just
we found a better way to live our life
now. It's no you are completely dead
and separated for eternity
in in your lostness.
And because of Christ's complete perfect
work of atonement and and salvation.
Now you are made alive in
Christ Jesus and thus Begins the
the discipleship Adventure. Let
me say this and then we'll get finished. Then you
start the spiritual infant stage. This
is number one zero and one
the spiritual infant stage is this. All right?
Brand new Christians are very much like spiritual
infants and that they're just so stinking cute, aren't they?
I love their their in emotion,
like the the worship they
invite people this is incredible and but then
but then they, you know, they just don't have the spiritual
depth to be able to go past that just much and
so
How many of you have ever seen kids come
back from Youth Camp just completely fired up
and ready to win the world for Jesus, right and then
school starts a couple of weeks later and things simmer down a little
right, but so we're not satisfied.
The reason that you're here. We're not
satisfied.
with maintaining spiritual immaturity
we are looking at one day going from death
and to life and hopefully you've been able to share your spiritual start.
But now we're looking at going from spiritual infancy now
into spiritual past spiritual childhood
into spiritual young adulthood and
eventually spiritual Parenthood and we're gonna
study each of those stories. We're going to I mean
each of those stages we're going to understand what are
some phrases that you hear from those stages so
that we can and by the way, no one
is going to force this assessment on you. So I
think you're a two, you know, nobody's gonna do that, right? You're
gonna do this for yourself, you're gonna ask the
Lord to reveal to you and honesty where you belong in this these stages
so that you can advance in the right direction.